for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out
movie University com thank you and enjoy
so in this video I'm going to talk about
how to name hydrates or hydrated ionic
compounds even though I'm not going to
really talk about them too much
otherwise I just want to talk about how
to name them that way if you see them
you do know how to name them okay so
what are they hydrates or hydrated ionic
compounds are pretty much exactly what
they sound like there are they are ionic
compounds that have a particular number
of water molecules associated with each
formula unit so when ionic compound
that's hydrated ionic compound that has
some water molecules associated with it
it's pretty straightforward definition
as far as the formulas go you'll often
see the ionic compound formula followed
by a little bullet a little bullet and
right after that bullet will be some
number that is a coefficient for the
number of water molecules associated
with that ionic compound so as far as
naming them you'll name the ionic
compound okay according to ionic
compound names and you'll just add a
prefix it prefix if I can spell that
correctly prefix indicating the number
of hydrogen's followed by the word
hydrate okay and the prefix of course
will be one of the Greek numerical
prefixes shown here to the right so
examples we have mgs 03 and then we have
a little bullet and then five waters
okay so the first thing we're going to
do is give the ionic compound name so
the ionic compound there is MGS 03 so
what is that well that is magnesium with
a 2 plus an S 03 2 minus that is a
sulfite so this is magnesium sulfate
okay and after that we're going to put
prefix hydrate so what's the prefix for
545 is Penta so it's going to be Penta
followed by hydrate so that'll be Penta
hydrate so this hydrate is magnesium
sulfate salts to me magnesium sulfate
pentahydrate okay but this one we've got
see you there see us 04 so that's coming
from cu 2 + + s 0 for 2 minus right to
give us cu 2 s 0 for 2 but that
simplifies down to just see us 04 so
that is copper to sulfate that is copper
to sulfate okay and we've got seven
what's the prefix 477 waters we have
hepta so that's going to be heptahydrate
so that's how you would name it that
hydrate that's pretty much it pretty
simple straightforward hope that video
is helpful thanks for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
Like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying